[Musique]
dans sa famille on brille à la fois dans
le foot et la politique lui a d'abord
préféré le ballon rond mais il préside
aujourd'hui la délégation aux outrem à
[Musique]
l'Assemblée bonjour David ran bonjour
alors le premier jour d'un député à
l'Assemblée national c'est forcément un
moment qui mêle un peu de fierté et
d'émotion sauf que pour vous les choses
se sont pas forcément bien passées ça a
été marqué par un incident que vous avez
raconté vous-même en prenant la parole
dans l'hémicycle c'était à l'occasion
d'un débat sur la politique
d'immigration de la
France suite à mon élection au mois de
juin je suis arrivé à l'Assemblée et
j'avais pas encore le le badge je suis
arrivé aux porortes de l'assemblée et
pour me renseigner donc je pe pas
rentrer j'ai j'ai sonné et une personne
est sortie et je dis bonjour m'a répondu
bonjour et la première chose qu'elle m'
dit avant même que je puisse m'exprimer
monsieur les livraisons c'est de l'autre
côté on m'a tout de suite ramené à quoi
à ma couleur de peau alors vous dites
que vous n'avez pas été blessé par cet
incident que vous en avez même souri
pourquoi parce Queen fait j'avais déjà
été marqué par ça dans dans mon enfance
de ma jeunesse donc je me suis construit
avec ça en tête vous AZ vous avez pris
l'habitude oui c'est c'était pas nouveau
mais ça m'a permis en tout cas d'être un
trait d'union par rapport au débat qu'il
y avait par rapport à l'immigration et
ce que peut ressentir une personne lors
qu'elle arrive un endroit qui ne
ressemble pas à celui qui chez qui est
l'arrive entre guillemets donc le regard
qu'on porte sur autru extrêmement
important donc ne pas se ne pas sentir
que nous soyons rejetés au travers du
regard et ça c'est très important et le
fait que ça vous soit arrivé dans une
institution comme l'Assemblée nationale
qu'on considère un peu comme étant la
maison de tous les Français ça a une
signification politique particulière
pour vous oui ça veut dire que nos
institutions encore n'ont pas fait n'ont
pas
fait le deuil de de cette histoire de de
la France parce que au travers de nos
institutions ça veut dire que la
discrimination soin toujours et c'est
pas normal ce n'est pas normal que
c'estàdire que elle prend aissance au
cœur de nos institutions mais vous le
voyez souvent je prends l'exemple pour
démontrer par rapport à l'élaboration
des loi les territoires d'autr mè sont T
sont toujours géré à la marge à la fin
de de la loi h on dit bon pour les
territoires deè ça va être légiféré par
ordonance ou par décret il y a pas de
débat il y a pas en il y a pas de
discussion il y a pas de prise en compte
des réalité donc ça veut dire que même
au cœur même de l'élaboration de la loi
on voit que tous les territoires sont
pas logés à la même enseigne et c'est ça
c'est l'un des moteurs de votre
engagement vous dites que souvent l'État
français tolère outre mer des choses qui
ne tolèent pas en métropole sur des
choses basiques comme l'accès à l'eau à
l'électricité c'est ça qui vous motive
aujourd'hui c'est lutter contre une
autre forme de discrimination qui est
plus Terri territoriale mais c'est
exactement ça je prends pour un exemple
simple le taux de chômage aujourd'hui la
voasine 9 % sur dans l'Hexagone nos
territoires de façon structurelle
voisine toujours entre 24 25 % euh et
l'autre chiffre qui est déterminant dans
dans la dans la situation vous prenez
aujourd'hui dans dans nos territoire
quasiment un actif sur deux ne fait rien
du tout il est pas au chômage il est pas
en formation il ne travaille pas ça veut
dire qu'on a pas tout le monde qui est
sur les écrans radar concernant le
chômage ça veut dire que vous vous
prenez ces chiffres là et vous les
ramenez à l'échelle de l'Hexagone il y a
le bon bat de combat qui qui est déclaré
pour sortir de cette situation là
regardez les efforts qui sont fait sur
l'exagone pour pour passer bientôt l'
espère au plein emploi mais on parle
d'un delta de 9 % en plein emploi c'est
quand on arrive à 5 % donc il y a 4 % de
marge à à faire alors que no territoire
c'est 24 25 % c'est que vous avez 20
points et et et quand onand on connait
le tissu économique et social ça va être
extrêmement compliqué d'atteindre cela
lors de votre première candidature au
législative en 2017 vous aviez parmi vos
adversaires votre V propre tante Juliana
riman ancienne députée de guyan de 2002
à 2007 et si on remonte à la génération
d'avant vous avez un de vos grand-père
qui a été maire de courou l'une des
principales villes de de Guyane pendant
42 ans ease riman ça donne un peu
l'impression que que la politique elle
est inscrite dans votre ADN familiale
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquez
c'est une fierté en tout cas mon
grand-père qui a qui a euvré beaucoup
avec le développement de la ville de
courou pendant 42 ans qui qui était un
maire de droite qui était la famille du
RPR proche de Jacques Chirac et et pour
autant il a fait beaucoup dans dans le
social au travers de sa commune par
rapport au réalité qui qui l'entourait
et c'est là c'est son intelligence au
quotidien de répondre aux dolances de
ses concitoyens et d'amener des réponses
positives plus souvent que rarement on
va dire ça comme ça et il a quandême une
grande différence entre eux enfin votre
tante et votre grand-père et vous c'est
queux étaient engagés à droite vous à
gauche c'est ça come viennent d'où vos
valeurs de gauche qui vous les a
transmises ma grand-mère ma ma
grand-mère paternelle euh avec qui à un
moment donné j'ai j'ai vécu quelques
années et celle qui m'a transmis toutes
ses valeurs humaines c'est le respect de
l'autre l'acceptation de l'autre même
s'il vous semble pas elle n'a pas été
all à l'école longtemps elle arrêtter
l'école elle avait 11 ans parce qu'il
fallait qu'elle s'occupe à l'époque vous
savez comment ça se passait il fallait
s'occuper de la maison des des petites
sœurs des petits frères et et pour
autant elle avait une sagesse elle avait
une approche de la vie au quotidien
c'est pour ça c'était pour moi c'était
une très grande dame et et euh et je si
je suis là aujourd'hui c'est en grande
partie grâce à elle pendant longtemps
euh vous avez porté un regard très
critique sur la sur la politique sur la
classe politique aussi j'ai retrouvé une
citation de vous en 2016 donc juste
avant que vous vous engageiez en
politique quand même un an avant on
laisse les politiques voter des lois à
la con qui ne valent pas un COPEC
qu'est-ce que vous reprochiez à la
politique et aux hommes politiques ben
la non prise en compte de réalité des
territoires regardez nos territoires
ultramarins c'est c'est ce sont mes mots
mais pour moi je qualifie ça de scandale
depuis 46 nous sommes passés en
département on est s sortie de colonie
passé en département français je
rappelle qui qui devait s'appeler la loi
d'assimilation mais qui est devenu la
loi départementalisation avec les
successions d'évolution de loi par la
suite et et on a l'impression qu'on
reste effecé dans le temps à différents
niveaux et c'est là que je me dis qu'il
y a un problème les lois qui ont été
votées en tout cas pour pour
l'application sur no territoire ne
valait pas un clou au contraire on nous
a mis dans une situation qui est
dramatique aujourd'hui et ça faut pas
qu'on ait peur de d'utiliser les les
bons mots la bonne sémantique qui
pourrait heurter ou choquer mais
néanmoins ça do servir à prendre
conscience qu'on doit sortir de ce
système de cette situation parce que il
y a des hommes et des femmes et des
enfants qui sont en grande souffrance au
quotidien en tout cas ce regard là sur
la politique vous a un peu éloigné de la
politique à vos débuts vous avez préféré
vous engager dans le syndicalisme chez
EDF en Guyane c'est là où vous étiez
salarié hein employé et c'est comme ça
qu'au Printant 2017 vous êtes devenu
l'une des figures l'un des porte-paroles
de ce grand mouvement social qui a
bloqué toute la Guyane pendant plusieurs
semaines et ce qui est surprenant c'est
que ce mouvement il était lui-même très
hostile à la politique son mode c'était
pas de politique et c'est ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment-là qui vous a
convaincu de vous engager en politique
oui parce qu'on a c'éit moment
déterminant pour moi parce que c'est là
qu'on prend conscience en fait que c'est
dans la sphère politique que tous décid
euh on peut être en de on peut être en
dehors de la sphère politique on
participe aux activités aux aides tout
ce qu'on veut au quotidien mais les la
sphère de décision c'est dans le monde
politique et c'est dans ce sensl que
voulons uvrer à à ce changement tant
attendu tant voulu par par beaucoup
d'entre nous il était tout à fait normal
maintenant que je mis en gage et que à à
ma manière j'apporte ma ma pierre
l'édifice et donc vous êtes en engagé
dès 2017 alors ça n'a pas fonctionné aux
premières législative vous êtes présenté
deux fois et puis 2022 là vous êtes élu
mais alors depuis votre élection on sent
que vous êtes un peu
frustré vous avez expliqué j'ai de la
colère de la frustration j'aurais tant
souhaité faire plus mais je vois les
limites de
l'exercice ça veut dire que vous vous
sentez inutile en tant que député à
l'Assemblée mais quand vous vous mangez
des 493 régulièrement vous visitees à un
moment donné à quoi je serers mais
au-delà de ça le le travail
parlementaire il est il est il est
devenu compliqué parce qu'on voit que
dans la 5e République t qu'elle est
constituée l'exécutif à à la main sur
tout et c'est nous parlementaires qui
aujourd'hui depuis 2017 le parlementaire
ne peut plus être exécutif euh pour moi
le parlementaire cherche sa place encore
dans tout cet échiqué politique dans ce
fonctionnement de la 5e République c'est
bien pour ça que il y a des frustrations
ce qui me concerne lorsqu'on a volonté
vraiment que les choses bougent
concrètement on a cette frustration que
des choses peuvent prendre du temps où
on n'est pas forcément écouté à
différents niveaux et que surtout les
décisions prises ne sont pas forcément
en adéquation avec les réalités des
différents territoires concernés donc il
y a et puis il y a cette colère aussi
cette colère que je veux bonifier pour
pour permettre à nos territoires de
d'évoluer positivement parce que non on
peut plus cautionner ça aujourd'hui
concrètement le fait qu'on veille
légiférer son nous qu'on prend des
décisions sans nous ou bien encore que
l'on veuille faire des choses sans nous
concerter ça veut dire que tout ce qui
va sortir infé sera contre nous euh vous
présidez quand même aujourd'hui la
délégation aux oututres maires à
l'Assemblée est-ce que ça vous donne pas
un levier politique pour peser sur les
décisions pour avoir une vraie influence
si en fait oui et non en tant que
président de délégation la délégation
n'est pas une
commission elle pas les mêmes pouvoirs
néanmoins on est on Ess avvoir de cette
délégation là de mener des travau à bien
de démontrer objectivement les
nécessités de de bouger sur différentes
lignes chose qui n'est pas simple bien
sûr il y a ce jeu euh de discussion
connaiss savoir d'influence connaissvoir
avec avec l'exécutif pour qu'il puisse
entendre comprendre et mettre en œuvre
les bonnes décisions c'est j'ai envie
dire ça comme ça mais après j'ai envie
de dire aussi on part de loin ce n'est
pas simple il faut il faut avoir la
capacité à écouter tout le monde à
discuter avec tout le monde et à à
essayer de prendre des décisions qui qui
puisse rassembler le maximum pour peser
voilà euh je voulais quand même vous
entendre sur un événement dont on a pas
mal parlé dans les médias au mois de
septembre 2022 c'était au début de cette
nouvelle législature le premier match de
foot de l'équipe parlementaire de
l'équipe de députés de l'Assemblée
nationale on en a beaucoup parlé parce
que à l'époque tous les membres de
l'équipe qui étaient députés de gauche
ont refusé de jouer au côté des députés
du rassemblement national alors je dis
tout sauf un on vous voit sur ces images
vous vous avez tenu à jouer
pourquoi tous les jours nous avons des
concitoyens qui sont confrontés à à ce à
différentes situations et moi comme je
l' rappelé moi en tant que député je je
je on se côtoit régulèrement dans les
dans l' scène de l'Assemblée nationale
on échange on discute on peut ne pas
être d'accord et pour moi le lieu le le
terrain de football un lieu sportif ne
do pas d'être le lieu d'une
expression politique de la sort ça c'est
mon avis personnel c'est celui de
l'ancien entraîneur de foot qui a qui
s'est occupé de gamin en guyan c'est
c'est ça moi je suis éducateur sportif
aussi donc pour moi le sport doit
rassembler et même au travers des
discussions des débats qu'on peut avoir
sur des postur peut-être différente au
départ ces discussions contradictoires
peuvent emmener l'un ou l'autre à
évoluer sur sa position initiale moi je
crois en ce débat contradictoire il
n'est pas nécessaire en tout cas qu'on
puisse avoir des des postures fermées je
crois en la force de la discussion les
échanges entre les hommes et les femmes
le foot d'un mot dans votre famille il a
occupé une place importante vous avez
deux frères qui ont été joueurs
professionnels vous-même vous avez joué
je crois en National 2 vous vous rêvz
d'être joueur pro ou rêver non en fait
ça faisait partie des des possibilités
mais surtout après grande fierté de voir
que mon grand frère qui a ouvert la
porte mon petit frère à la Val mon mon
petit frère à sent qui ont pu
aujourd'hui à un moment donné goûter à
ce niveau-là et et rendre leur
expérience aussi maintenant sur le
territoire guyanais donc le football le
sport fait partie intégrante de nos vies
en tout cas dans notre famille on va
passer à notre quiz à présent je vous
explique le le principe je vais
commencer une phrase et vous allez
devoir la la terminer c'est bon on y va
les députés devraient s'inspirer du
football pour se rassembler justement ce
dont on ce dont on par se rassembler et
avoir une force de avoir une force de
cohésion collective les députés qui
découvrent que je viens de Guyane me
demande souvent comment ça est-ce que il
y a des méconnaissance territo total et
souvent je leur dis al j'ai j'ai invité
plusieurs de nos collègues à venir en
guyan à venir découvrir ce territoire
qui aura beaucoup à à à leur montrer à
leur démontrer que un avenir radiu peut
être possible en tout cas pour nous
enfin si mes enfants se lancent en
politique je leur dirais réfléchissez
bien avant d'y aller ah oui pourquoi
parce que c'est un monde qui est
extrêmement hypocrite et méchant ah ça
donne pas envie là ce que vous dites NON
faut être bien armé psychologiquement
faut être bien armé donc vous les
dissuaderiez pas mais vous non je le je
leur dirais surtout d'êre d'être d'être
une personne aboutie humainement
complètement avant de se lancer avant de
se lancer et ça va au-delà de l'âge
c'est par rapport aux événements de la
vie on arrive à aboutir par rapport
chose qu'on a traversé et on pourra
effectivement mener ce sur de combat
mais si on n pas abouti faut pas y aller
merci beaucoup David ran d'être venu
dans la politique et moi merci à
[Musique]
vous